محمد دياب ابراهيم المصري او كما يشتهر
بمحمد الضيف هو القائد العام لكتائب
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس واحد
ابرز قاده المقاومه الفلسطينيه حاولت
اسرائيل اغتيال الضيف سبع مرات كان اخرها
عام
2014 واشهرها عام 2002 عندما قصفت مروحيات
الاباتشي سيارته بحي الشيخ رضوان في قطاع
غزه لكن تلبيب اعترفت لاحقا بانه نجى
باعجوبه ووفقا للصحف الاسرائيليه فان
تقديرات جهاز الموساد اكدت على مدار العقد
الماضي ان الضيف تعرض لاصابات مباشره في
اربع محاولات اغتيال جعلته مشلولا لا
يستطيع المشي على قدميه ويجلس على كرسي
متحرك لكن صحيفه معاريف العبريه نشرت
تقريرا يفيد بعثور الجيش الاسرائيلي على
مقاطع فيديو في غزه تظهر قائده كتائب
القسام محمد الضيف وبصحه جيده وهو يتجول
على قدميه لكن بعرج طفيف دون ان يستخدم
كرسيا متحركا خلافا للتقديرات
الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيليه السابقه اذا
ضجه كبيره احدثتها هذه التقارير في
اسرائيل صحف عبريه عده وصفت الامر بالفشل
الاستخباراتي والبعض الاخر قال ان محمد
الضيف نجح في خداع اسرائيل طوال هذه
السنوات وصحف اخرى راته احراجا كبيرا
لجهاز الموسات ومنذ بدء العدوان
الاسرائيلي الاخير على قطاع غزه وضع جيش
الاحتلال محمد الضيف على راس اهدافه للحرب
والقى قبل ايام منشورات على غزه وعد فيها
بمكافاه ماليه قدرها 100000 دولار مقابل
تقديم اي شخص معلومات موثقه عن الضيف اذا
كيف علقتم انتم على ما نشرته الصحف
الاسرائيليه دعونا نبدا هنا بابراهيم
اذا يقول ابراهيم فشل اخر للاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه شبيه بالاخفاق التي اصبحت
تتكشف بشكل مستمر منذ طوفان الاقصى الوهم
الذي صنعوه بان الموسات خارق بدا يتلاشى
نصل معكم الى
لميس تقول يعتقدون انه قدره الشخص في
اطرافه بل هي في عقيدته ولو بقى في عرق
واحد ينبض محمد الضيف منذ سنين وهو او وهم
يحاولون الايقاع به دون جدوى ايضا ننتقل
الى وديع وديع يقول هنا اخطاء الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه بالجمله كذب الشباك ساب كذب
الشباك سابقا وقال انهم اصابو والان
يعترفون بخطئهم ولا يعرفون كيف ينجحون في
تحييده رغم محاولاتهم اخيرا نصل معكم الى
جاسم اذا يقول جاسم هنا مع اي احتلال
واستخبارات ضائعه نتعامل مساد لا يعرف
الوضع الصحي لابرز قاده المقاومه ولا يعرف
معلومات عنه وكل ما كان لديه من معلومات
سابقه تبين انها خاطئه اذا ردا على هذه
التقارير قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه لم
يتفاجا بظهور الضيف بصحه جيده وهو يمشي
على قدميه مؤكدا ان المعلومات الاخيره
تتوافق مع ما كان معروفا للجيش والشباك في
السنوات الاخيره وبحسب تصريحات مسؤ امنيين
للقناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه